Hi, I'm Nick Phillips with Hikes You Can Do.
Hi, I'm Kevin with Hikes You Can Do.
Hello everyone and welcome to a very special edition of Hikes You Can Do.
Today, we find ourselves in the Big Santa Anita Canyon.
We're gonna be doing a four to five-mile loop hike.
And we're gonna be hiking on the Solstice Canyon trail.
So, let's go check it out.
We created Hikes You Can Do as a video information source...
...for people to get a little bit of inspiration, a little bit of information.
From the bridge, if you climb up towards the river,...
...you get your own private bigger waterfall.
It's okay to get away for physical fitness, for mental fitness; get out and go hiking.
Get away from the city, get away from the traffic.
Because when they go outside, they have this life-altering experiences.
And then they share those experiences with their friends, their family.
They come out and it all happened because of one little video that they saw online.
We're trying to meld the technology.
Use the computer to get you outside.
You get the inspiration, you get in the car and then you go on a hike.